on a parlé de courage et de solidarité
depuis le début de cette émission mais
ce soir on en a un exemple 120 personnes
ont suivi une formation accélérée
d'urgence pour devenir pompier forestier
c'est la soft feuille qui organisait ses
formations l'accord de terminer cette
formation elle va être déployée dans la
bitibi au cours des prochains jours même
déjà demain mon invité fait partie de
ces personnes courageuses qui ont suivi
la formation elle est jeune médecin elle
va commencer sa spécialité sarida sa
résidence en spécialité le 4 juillet en
Ontario elle va être gynécologue
chirurgienne madame wave bienvenue je
vous ai vous êtes originaire de Val d'Or
et là qu'est-ce que vous a poussé à
cette à vous engager et bien ma mère qui
est à Val d'Or m'envoyer beaucoup de
photos de la région à montrant beaucoup
de fumer un peu partout le matin n'était
plus respirable de mon côté j'ai la
chance d'être formé avec l'équipe de
sauvetage bén
a fait appel à l'aqprs association
québecoise de bénévoles en recherche et
sauvetage donc à travers eux j'ai pu
être déployé pour porter main forte à la
sauce vous avez suivi une formation qui
devait être assez difficile non
physiquement quand même donc on a eu
l'appel de samedi dernier on nous a dit
qu'on avait 24 heures pour se rendre
dimanche soir à la ville de Québec donc
pour deux jours et demi à raison de 10 à
12 heures par jour on a été formé dans
la classe avec la théorie et aussi sur
le terrain physiquement alors vous venez
de terminer votre formation de médecine
vous allez la poursuivre pour devenir
spécialiste est-ce que c'est un grand
risque pour vous de vous engager comme
ça c'est pas un métier facile
oui oui donc c'est sûr que ça porte des
risques la seule feuille nous encre bien
on est beaucoup formations au niveau de
la sécurité puis on a beaucoup
d'équipement de protection on eu des
cours aussi pour savoir pouvoir prédire
les feux et pouvoir
ne pas se mettre en danger donc je me
sens en sécurité grâce à ces formations
là mais c'est sûr que sur le terrain ça
peut être différent oui et puis est-ce
que vous avez un peu peur
personnellement j'ai pas peur pour moi
encore une fois on a bien été formé puis
on a des chefs de lutte des chefs
d'équipe qui reste en sécurité les
hélicoptères pas trop pour ça c'est
qu'on n'est jamais trop près du feu puis
que les fruits nous encercle pas mais je
dois dire que j'ai peur pour le Québec
parce qu'on ne sait pas à quoi le Québec
veut ressembler à la fin de tout ça
est-ce que vous étiez que déjà quelqu'un
de sensibilisé au changement climatique
à leurs effets choisir que oui c'est sûr
que c'est facile quand on n'est pas prêt
du Nord et des feux de penser que tout
va bien mais on peut voir avec la
qualité de l'air qui était très affecté
dans les grandes villes récemment que
même si les filles sont au nord c'est
tout le Québec qui brûle et puis on l'a
vu il y a un instant aux États-Unis
également il y a pas la pollution la
pollution ne connaît pas de frontière en
fait et vous connaissez bien votre
région qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de
voir tous ces villages
municipalité affectée de voir autant de
milliers de personnes évacuées c'est
très difficile c'est des forêts dans
laquelle j'ai grandi dans lesquels je
retourne pour moi c'est ma maison c'est
mon chez moi et puis mon côté médical
est très conscient que la fumée et les
feux sont
des facteurs qui affectent grandement
les populations rurales et population
autochtones de manière disproportionnée
et ça l'impact évidemment de la santé de
ces populations parce que il y a des
feux dans le Nord généralement mais qui
se rapprochent autant des populations
c'est ça qui est extrêmement n'est-ce
pas
et qu'est-ce qu'elle a entendu
poursuivre
dans votre médecin avec cette
préoccupation environnementale donc j'ai
eu la chance de faire plusieurs stages
et formations en médecine en milieu
sauvage qui est un milieu médical qui
commence à prendre de l'ampleur avec les
gens qui vont de plus en plus en région
et faire des activités dehors donc
j'espère pouvoir continuer ma médecine
et aider les communautés
rural dans le Nord avec ma profession de
obstétricienne et aussi mon côté médical
parce qu'on dit beaucoup que les
communautés autochtones sont parmi les
plus affectés exactement oui parce que
sont elles vivent éloignées avec peu de
ressources et il y en a qui résiste à
vouloir quitter leur communauté vous
comprenez pourquoi il y en a qui
hésitent à quitter c'est chez eux c'est
leur maison j'ai travaillé aussi dans le
Nord nous n'avons puis je dois dire que
les gens s'en sont appartenance envers
leur communauté puis la vie en région
rurale elle est fantastique pour l'avoir
vécu donc je comprends totalement leur
désir de rester espérez vous que ces
événements soient un point tournant pour
éveiller les gens au risque des
changements climatiques à l'urgence
d'agir c'est malheureux qu'on en soit
arrivé là pour que les gens se
réveillent c'est sûr que maintenant les
grandes villes sont affectés je pense ça
va allumer le ça va allumer beaucoup de
personnes comme je l'ai dit tout le
monde brûle avec ses fleurs donc
j'espère que les gens vont être plus
enclin apprendre à action avec
changement climatique c'est presque la
panique aux États-Unis quand les indices
de pollution monte au-delà de 400 comme
c'était le cas aujourd'hui à New York
n'est-ce pas exactement oui soit vous
partez demain dans le Nord pour
l'instant je retourne à Ottawa commencé
mon équipement puis par la suite je suis
en contact avec la base de Maniwaki pour
aider à Val d'Or très bien leur courage
est-ce qu'on peut rester en contact bien
sûr merci d'avoir fait le détour par
notre studio c'est très apprécié mon
amour merci à vous et bonne chance dans
tout vos projets nous engagements merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]